whoa whoa whoa okay ouch hot computer
this updated version of hot potato why
you so defensive per first use yeah
remember that I am the funny captains
for the Friskies this year I mean this
video explaining it
this piece home Wow pal informative of
me me the freight skis are one step
closer to crowning the kacct superstar
extraordinaire I think a pillow the
funny category for The Frisky isn't I
asked you guys to submit your funny cat
videos and the Vanaras alum to three
finalists and I have accepted three
finalists I have not seen the videos yet
so you and I are going to watch them
together for the very first time we're
both the mid experiences for the very
first time that joke won't make it in
the final cut let's watch the three cat
videos oh my god I don't think that song
moves it that guys are really good at
massages it's the cutest thing I've ever
seen
they're perfectly framed also this looks
like a weird porn it's not at the moment
that the cat turns demonic and probably
lunges for the door one jealous of that
cat's massage skills - don't know how
good it got it three beautiful porch
that cloning alone
okay let's look at the next one oh this
cat is drunk no way they can't scared
because there are a pair of socks really
close to that sandal and that's a bad
mix it is awful
oh that cat hates ugly fashion those
sandals are terrifying yes touch it but
oh you almost got it that time
oh I love a cat that stands up against
terrible fashion
next video looking very much into my
heart and soul you know sometimes the
simplest things are the best I feel like
I can't clearly knew that it was never
going to get through the glass but it
had committed and it wasn't gonna let
the camera person prove them wrong there
you go they're three finalists for the
Friskies in the category funny
you can vote daily at the Friskies comm
for your favorites
please vote if you care if you don't
care just vote one because it's very
empowering and two every vote gets one
can of cat food donated to charity not
people charity to animal charities and
if a video in my category the funny
category receives the most votes overall
I had to donate $10,000 to the cat
charity of my choice I know it's very
exciting so make sure you go vote
because I really really really want to
donate $10,000 to account charity and
that's it
I don't know someone donate some antacid
to my stomach charity